hey 42 here fire can bring entire
buildings to the ground in hours and can
devastate entire forests that have stood
for thousands of years it's one of the
most powerful forces in nature but what
exactly is fire when we stare into a
flame what are we actually looking at
let's find out the ancient Greeks
believed that the universe was made up
of four basic elements fire water earth
and air their belief was built on the
premise that you can touch and feel all
of these things they believed they were
the building blocks of all matter we now
know that this isn't the case
but the ancient Greeks got one thing in
particular very very wrong they
completely misclassified fire because
fire isn't an element at all also it's
not really matter either well not
completely anyway fire is a mixture of
gases such as oxygen carbon dioxide
carbon monoxide and water vapour to name
a few
mixtos gases with photons of light and
thermal energy and you pretty much have
the building blocks of fire fire is
actually the visible side effect of what
happens when matter undergoes a change
of state by means of a chemical reaction
of course you can't blame the Greeks
they did pretty well considering their
level of technological advancement but
let's see if we can do a little better
with everything we know now about us and
elements and chemical reactions fire
isn't just fire there's no element or
chemical substance known as fire so what
is it well fire is the name we have
given to a visual phenomenon which
occurs when matter burns in true fire is
a complex beast and in order to explain
exactly what it is we need to break it
down into its core components the first
and most important components of fire is
the fuel this is what is actually
burning take a candle for example the
fuel is the wax when we set the wick
alight the heat causes the molecules in
the wax which are mostly carbon and
hydrogen to move about erratically
this causes the Cova
and chemical bonds which are holding the
molecule together to break apart
releasing individual hydrogen and carbon
atoms as well as hydrogen carbon
molecules these individual atoms and
molecules form a gas which travels
upwards from the candle this process is
known as pyrolysis the gas travels
upwards because of gravity the air
immediately surrounding the candle flame
gets heated or the colder surrounding
the hotter puts pressure on the hot air
because cold air is more dense than hot
air the pressure exerted from the cold
air pushes the hot air upwards and the
heat rises as this happens the cold air
replaces the hot air and gets heated up
itself this process repeats itself for
as long as the flame is alight this is a
process known as convection but heat
only rises in this fashion in gravity
rich environments in outer space flames
don't travel upwards they instead
radiate in a perfectly spherical pattern
from the source so now we have
established fires second component gas
the elements that make up the gas in
fire depend entirely on the fuel if you
change the fuel you also change the
properties of the fire but there's still
two more components to fire light and
heat so far we have to do that fire is
mostly gas but gases don't usually give
off light so where does the light come
from this is where oxygen comes in we
all know that oxygen or some other
highly oxygenated substance is required
to make a fire and keep it burning so
back to the candle when the gas rises
from the candle the atoms in the gas are
still moving around vigorously because
of the heat these excited but clumsy
atoms collide with oxygen atoms in the
air when the two atoms meet they
interact with one another to cause a
chemical reaction some of the energy
from this reaction gets released as
photons of light and so we see a bright
blue orange red or white flicker this
process is known as chemiluminescence
the remaining atoms that don't collide
with oxygen get carried up the flame and
eventually he took to a level where they
give off visible light this is known as
incandescent
now imagine billions of these tiny
chemiluminescence and incandescent
chemical reactions producing billions of
tiny little flickers of light every
second this is what makes a flame burn
so brightly the color of the flame
depends on the molecules that make up
the fuel and subsequently the gas which
it releases when burned the temperature
at which it burns also affects the color
you can therefore estimate the
temperature of a flame based on its
color a red flame is anywhere from 525
to a thousand degrees Celsius our ranges
between a thousand and 1,200 degrees
Celsius under white flame is around
1,500 degrees Celsius but a blue flame
is significantly hotter at around 3,000
degrees Celsius and so to the final
component of fire heat why is fire hot
well this is really quite simple
the heat you feel from a flame is just
the energy being released from the
billions of chemical reactions occurring
between the atoms in the flame and the
oxygens in the air all chemical
reactions either give off energy as a
by-product or absorb energy the chemical
reactions which happen in a fire are
exothermic which means they give off
energy as opposed to endothermic which
is when a reaction absorbs energy so to
summarize what exactly is it you're
seeing when you look into a flame you're
seeing a gas undergoing billions of tiny
chemical reactions which are giving off
photons of light and thermal energy oh
and you're also looking at millions of
tiny diamonds being created and
disappearing right before your eyes yes
diamonds in a flame the carbon atoms
released from the fuel come together to
create diamonds nanoparticles millions
of times per second thanks for the view
subscribe for more thoughty2